solve for x we have the absolute value
of 2x minus 15 is equal to negative 15.
now let's think about it a little bit
can we get an absolute value of any
number being equal to negative 15.
remember absolute value means your
distance away from zero so even if we
take the absolute value of a negative
number if we take the absolute value of
negative 15 we get positive 15. if we
take the absolute value of positive 15
we still get positive 15. both of them
are 15 away from zero there's you can't
be a negative distance away from zero
you're always going to be a positive
distance away from zero the smallest
distance you can be away from zero is
zero and that's that's when you're at
zero so the absolute value of zero is
zero that's the pos the smallest
possible value that you can get when you
take the absolute value of anything so
there's no way no matter what you put in
here that if we take the absolute value
we could get a negative number so this
right here has no solution no
no solution